Michael Rapaport you're a perfect person
to ask about this we're just talking
about Serena yes and everything going on
with Serena's you see the cartoon
there's this Australian newspaper yes do
you see the I see the racial nosov it
Jim disagrees with me in a way no sir
I mean I see the racial nosov it I see
the racial nosov it absolutely um but
you know it is a caricature and you know
I don't think it's Shh I see the
racialist of it I mean listen the
[ __ ] political correct police and
okay so the dude made a racial thing
what do you want to do to the cover to
because there's the it's just a whole
cover of caricatures one one they just
did this with her these got a bunch of
them the whole kiss economically the
cover cover but that's what the cover
looks right they all look creased
everyone's account is you're fat and you
know distorted and all that stuff so
yeah I mean I I don't I mean you know
they like look at Trump you know I mean
is that racist he looks I mean it's
something he looks like a piece of [ __ ]
you know you know III think that the
Serena thing you know I could say about
the serene away I'm Serena Williams
biggest fan how I [ __ ] love her she's
more my favorite athletes I've always
loved her her and Venus heard their
story their whole up you know their
whole up takeover in tennis their father
um you know how they came into the game
and also her father a tennis player I
don't know much about their their father
ya know their father oh never play
tennis but he saw he so he was watching
tennis and he was like my daughters are
gonna be tennis players he learned about
tennis I'm it's a crazy story in Compton
they had no tennis courts you know he
read a book about it watch some matches
and he was like started coaching not one
daughter two daughters to be the best
tennis players ever that is odd right
that he just had idea like just if you
put it in a movie but like this isn't
yeah
is that what levar ball is kind of
trying to do with his kids yes
it's girls right it's becomes in tennis
yeah so it's so I mean that when they
did it it was like I mean when they came
into the game black girls in tennis with
braided hair it was like and these were
not like girls that were like meek and
and soft like they were like we're here
we're kicking [ __ ] ass right like
they created the whole genre of tennis
like the brand of tennis they play will
only be played by the Williams sisters
it's like Smash Mouth tennis so there's
stories you should check it out
um anyway so to answer a question
especially after seeing the artists
other work which of course no one else
does I mean I don't get into this okay
so if it's if it's he sees it is what it
is
to me he's a cover of caricatures about
the week's stories I kind of see the
racial in this of it but like I said I
don't like okay like got it like that
yeah the other characters are [ __ ] up
too the real [ __ ] up they're all
[ __ ] up because how else would you
make a caricature like it she's just
being she looks like she's being
petulant and being a baby because she
has John who is that racist right look
at the size of his lips look at his lip
his lips true are huge and he looks
[ __ ] the semi [ __ ] obviously the
writer the artist accentuates something
he's seasoned you look at you know Trump
as much as I can't stand him in his fat
flabby neck it's way bigger than it is
in real life and it is pretty big in
real life but he accentuated like an in
Kim jong-un he didn't like accentuate
the the Asian eyes you know never shut
well yeah they're open and also the
thing about her samus she's yelling like
you see her mouth had to be a say
because she's throwing a temper tantrum
this wasn't like she got pulled over
driving she was jumping she basically
jumping up and down stomping her a track
you got get he's saying that she's being
she's throwing a temper tantrum listen
III think that we are in such a [ __ ]
like crazy time in terms of you know
what is minoo the news cycle and it just
hang on to something and hang on to
something and and and and then and then
other things will just big things
important things right tragedies mm-hmm
school shootings will be like like for
an afternoon to blur hear it again
it's amazing still talking about Serena
Williams a cartoon or and we're still
talking about the Nike thing and then
when there's real things that happen to
real people it'll just be like you know
[ __ ] but we want to hang on to this
maybe the big one though race is the big
one it is the big marina thing happened
on Sunday when we didn't talk about it I
think when we didn't talk about it on
Monday I was like okay we're not gonna
talk about it on the show I guess it's
over
it's Wednesday we're finally getting to
it but it's cuz it's still a topic of
the day when you're right all this other
stuff that's real news kind of goes away
after about 24 hours and nothing comes
of it
nothing real news magic news so it's
crazy that you know the Kaepernick Nike
thing is still you know like these these
little random schools are weird we're
not using like you know and stuff and
and and and the racial implications
around the Kaepernick negative thing
it's like just say what is offensive
it's not because he's kneeling it's not
because the players are kneeling because
if they were kneeling for homelessness
if they were kneeling for lack of
funding in public schools no one would
say a [ __ ] word they'd be true
patriots heroes and and and and
ground-shaking you know important people
but it's black athletes kneeling for a
Cause that a lot of people don't see as
a cause and then it's the flag and the
embarrassment [ __ ] if they were
kneeling because of the amount of stray
dogs in the country people would be like
aren't these guys so sweet it's it's
like just say what the [ __ ] you have a
problem with stop trying to make it seem
like Patriots and and and and in his
offensive to the flag bull-fucking-shit
I'll let the military guys at objecto
cuz there's a lotta people that said
they support them no no but I mean are
the military guys that do don't support
it and are saying because like I fought
for this country a lot of them are
saying that the reason is just because
they feel it's disrespecting yeah
there's a lot of military people that
have said they don't have a problem with
it but the question is the military
people I think what you're asking is the
military people that object
are objecting for flag reason is early
race but I'm saying there's also
military people that are saying I don't
have no problem with it
sure but you're saying the people who
are objecting or a generation no no I'm
saying they like the the the the the
majority of the people that are
objecting you think it's a race thing
absolutely absolutely it's a racing and
I'm so sick of like just the one thing I
like about a certain kind of races is if
you say it right they're like then it's
cool right but like stop [ __ ] beating
around the bush get your [ __ ] big
races but you're saying yeah those
[ __ ] racist balls and say what the
[ __ ] you gotta say that is true I don't
want these black [ __ ] kneeling
it offends me
they have no right doing it they should
be happy to be making a living and
that's what the mentality is but don't
you think a lot of people don't think
that consciously like even deep down
that's how they feel it's not it's not
outward it's right it's right below
their mouth they don't know yeah and
some people I don't think even because
Patrice had a great point what time
exactly met a racist he said I've never
met or everyone says they're not they're
not even though you know there's a lot
of them and I think most people believe
that they're not even though you'd be
pretty much on their ideas they kind of
are pretty hard for this revival right
now you'd be a pretty hardcore revival
to come out and go like yeah Mauritius I
don't like blacks even to yourself I
think there are more people feeling
comfortable doing that now than maybe
yeah recently I think a lot of people
don't even like realize like no I don't
know I'm not most people you talk to
like no I'm not right but then you hear
what they're saying yeah a little bit
you are right I think there's a lot more
of that yeah then there is people being
outward I don't know what the more I say
I can't I don't know what it is I don't
care if they do or not it doesn't matter
to me either way right hander you don't
have to I don't give a [ __ ]
right but that and that I think I don't
care the Kaepernick's this good do the
commercial with them like who cares
that's the logical response right like
if you want a Neil Neil what differences
do what you want you don't want to wear
Nike don't wear Nike dumbass
Yeah right here I don't burn a [ __ ]
fetal but I also love to that that's
what becomes a story this idea that
people are burning their shoes they're
not burning their shoes burning your
shoes do people burn shoes nobody's
burning shoes made some keep people like
bought socks to cut them cut them up to
show it on Instagram give me a [ __ ]
that just means you need new socks
faster you're doing like a [ __ ] favor
right
it's so stupid but it's crazy it's a
crazy time how is your house your
podcast doing because you left bar stool
and you're doing okay
oh yeah we're doing better than ever you
are what happened with bar stool cuz I
wake up one morning is I can't you could
read between lines I can't talk about
that right now
about that about are there legalities
involved I'm not I'm not saying anything
about it and I say a lot about a lot of
things I've said things that could be
taken out of context in the first 15
minutes of this show bad thing so let's
just say I can't and I'm not gonna say
anything about it
will you okay and yeah but you are a guy
normally comfortable with talking about
anything but this is one you just is
there nor okay is there more to it than
just you said anybody that calls himself
a stoolie is an idiot and they said well
then you're fired
is there more to it than that I can't
comment on that right now
Wow interesting keep on that right for
you I mean most people do it you roll
the eye uation I can't comment or write
on that right now for you to not comment
there's something oh yeah there's a
lawyer involved
do you have any feeling on Pat McAfee
leaving did you know Pat yes he's a good
dude yeah you know it's I'm not
surprised
okay I am not surprised at all with what
happened or that he left uh with what
happened and that he decided to leave
because I think we're in any in any
world that if you're you know that
something is sort of appearing to be
something and it's not and you're about
your business and a man of integrity
eventually you're gonna be like I don't
need this right right right you think
that there will be a public update on
the Michael Rapaport barstool their
relationship do I think do you think in
the coming weeks
well I I don't speak on them you do not
so but there might be a public you know
you find out a public level will people
find out more information maybe but I
mean who know people people find out
about a lot of things I will not be
speaking on it at all but there could be
people talking there could be all that
talk about it I get it I get it I think
I'm picking up what you're putting down
yeah
you think you could smell with the
report
they smell that I think so so do you I
mean in this world that we live in
you're an outspoken guy a little bit but
I was thinking cuz you know I watched
the first season of a typical yes you
know this I was excited when I saw the
second season was that I haven't watched
it yet but it or not
why haven't you watched the whole thing
yet we it's only been it's been out five
days yes
do you worry because a typical is is
like this great sort of family show it's
about a mom it's about a family
the kid is autistic but it gets into
all-around family dynamics and you know
I don't wanna give any spoilers I guess
for the first season in case people
haven't seen it you should watch both
seasons but do you worry that at some
point your outspokenness is gonna take
away your opportunity to play a lovable
dad no I don't I don't worry about that
and and you know I'll say it has crossed
my mind I've had conversations with
different people about it in regards to
not going too far and what you say I
don't think I speak recklessly I think
that when I speak about things that are
important to me I do it from a place of
love even though sometimes I know that
I'm not right I've made mistakes I've
said things even that have nothing to do
with anything it really important that
you know when you I find this when I
tweet and I write is when I've gotten
into trouble when I verbalized myself on
a video I have had no problem when I
sweet when I when I put something in
writing right the sixth of the Detroit
the words for me you know you know as a
comedian and as a performer you know
innuendo sarcasm if inflection yeah yeah
yeah so if I go you know Jim is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's a statement of
fact I could Jim and Sam are [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I say it on Twitter then
there'll be like what the [ __ ] your
problem with Jim but i'ma go Jim and Jim
and Sam are [ __ ] [ __ ] those
[ __ ] guy you're gonna hear the
inflection
I'll break absolutely saying it is much
different Twitter takes away context too
because it's limited yes in a vacuum but
but just from like the inflection
jaemin's you know you can hear to see a
smile on my face yes or or or or you
could hear the tone of whatever make
something funny so I have found when I
tweet something that's when I've gotten
into like it's been misconstrued and at
times that go [ __ ] I didn't mean it like
that
um but I also know that if you're going
to do it like I don't I don't you know a
lot of times people get into this I'm
not gonna apologize I stand by what I
say and I don't think that that means
you're strong you're tough you're you're
a man of integrity I think sometimes you
should apologize you should clarify if
you're sorry or yeah or a few or if you
you didn't mean it to come off that way
sure you know especially if it's in when
you write something like so so you know
like I mean I stand by what I say I'm
not backing down on my pond all right
well you cannot do that but I if I know
like there's like there's no points in
that if you know that what you said was
misunderstood or you know uh you know
that your hair grows you shave it it
comes like that you you can grow you can
change you know ideology theories
thoughts can change you you know for
somebody like me that talks a lot of
[ __ ] sometimes you talk [ __ ] and and
when you get too close to a person you
could spit on them
I didn't mean to spit on you I'm just
talking [ __ ] so I apologize for Spit
annoying right that's a different level
of disrespect and the difference between
an apology that you mean when you say
something that comes off wrong yeah and
a groveling apology that's insincere
right
and in so in regards to a typical which
is you know started streaming last
Friday on and it's gone Netflix now
although Sam didn't see and Jim I don't
think you saw I don't even think you
know why the [ __ ] I'm here you know
first is great you know like I think
that you know the opportunity to play a
character that's different than my
public persona is great you know I've
had you know great opportunities
throughout my career you know to
sometimes get away from what people
might think I can do or
can't do as an actor and and this is
just another one of those opportunities
and it's also on a show that I think is
resonating with a lot of people for
different reasons so I'm really happy
about that as the as the reverse
happened cuz your your character is a
very sweet guy yes on a typical he's
kind of them oh I feel like your
character is the moral center ground of
the whole show right do like are there
people that like niceness and family
shows and stuff like that that watch
this show fall in love with you and then
like listen to your podcast or Twitter
or something like that and go like what
the hell is this guy's problem
I mean I haven't seen that yet but I'm
sure there are but you know worrying
like I you know we're in a different
time now with actors the mysterious
Dustin Hoffman Marlon Brando Robert De
Niro days are done you know there's only
the mystique yeah they like you won't
you can't be a born-and-bred movie star
at this point without the world knowing
a little bit about you you know there's
very few left DiCaprio's is is that but
he's been around for 20 years Ryan
Gosling's kind of on the tail end of
that but but aside from those guys who's
left do you think Nikolas in is still
one of those older guys but those guys
can do it yeah in furs like a 20 year
old guy and become a star now you need
to get a Twitter account you need that
social media following yeah you need
like we're gonna get you on Access
Hollywood you you you're gonna come on
here like that that Warren Beatty like
mystique Jack Nicholson mystique [ __ ]
that [ __ ] is it's a different business
model now yeah even Will Smith Julia
Roberts the president will smith is
vlogging yeah you know what I mean he's
got a YouTube but they could video to
you now just tie the idea of seeing a
celebrity talk on a talk show it used to
be like oh my god this one's talking now
you don't give a [ __ ] because they're
just they're talking in there and
they're periscope videos right it's
nothing special about it it's it's a
different time for the actors and stuff
like that and for me in regards to my
podcast and and you know my Instagram
which you know is caught on with a lot
of people for the shit-talking reasons
for the views I take whatever it is um
you know I tried to be as honest as I
possibly can and if I if I if I do say
something that that is offensive
and and that I regret then I'll deal
with that I'll deal with that do you
like the heat do you like the smoke cuz
I like when I post something and people
disagree with it I hate it
III hate getting people be like no
you're wrong on this I don't go like oh
it's a dialogue this is fun I'm like it
depends it depends I don't like it um I
don't like you know people just you know
coming at me I don't like if it's if my
intention of what I was saying is
misconstrued that I don't when they
think they know why you said it and you
it's like that is a lot more yeah and
like you know like oh you're racist
oh you're offensive I know you know like
academic kind of makes my um you know my
my my mop my flex I'm like [ __ ] you like
I go to pepper into it like [ __ ] you and
and that's my that's how I deal with it
because you know no one is righteous
you're on Twitter you ain't doing [ __ ]
you you're not righteous you're like you
know like well I can like come on please
and in my personal policy about
Instagram and Twitter is that if you say
something that I deem offensive to me
I'm going to look at your avatar that's
all I know about you you could look up
20-something years of Michael Rapaport
fine this picture this one that one this
all stuff I'm gonna talk about whatever
I see in the Avatar if it's your mom
your your cat your dog your kids
whatever I see in the app you won't take
the hire that's all you have that's what
you have so like well you're talking
about my wife I go yes look at this
animal but it's just it's just it's just
uh I don't know it is what it is because
because they have so much on you to go
on
you have nothing so when a guy's is
insulting you and you want to insult
them back it's difficult to do when you
know nothing about the person so you
either defend yourself which sounds too
defensive or you insult an egg there's
there's nothing you can say about right
which is why a lot of times just muting
or blocking works yes as a poet unless
you think it's a guy with if it's a guy
that has a decent amount of followers
and you know that he's speaking as
himself then you can address it but
exactly do you like Haley you but you
also like you know some actors are okay
just building a fanbase based on their
work yes it feels like you like having
an army of people that said
port you as you as Michael Rapaport is
the person with his point of view I do
like that and and um you know like it
just sort of happened you know if you
know it just sort of happened over the
last few years when I started doing
things my stuff whether it was the Tribe
Called Quest documentary or my book that
I think I came here to talk about him
mm-hmm
or whatever and and it brought out a
different sort of way that I share
myself and and and I and I I'm
comfortable with that I've I've always
been the same person it's just there
wasn't you know 70,000 talk shows there
was an Instagram it wasn't you know
YouTube stuff there wasn't all these
these forums where you could be like oh
you know so so you know people have sort
of seen it but it's not like I'm like
I've changed it's just sort of like I've
shared more of myself with the world in
terms of my I've always been a [ __ ] talk
I've that's I've that's how I started
got I got into comedy and got into you
know acting you know like my whole life
I talk [ __ ] you doing stand-up first yes
for a short period of time I was never
like at the level like I was never like
highly skilled stand-up and I was so
young but yeah I started doing stand-up
and then quickly started getting called
in for auditions and then when I started
acting like the first time I read a
scene off a page like it was just like
this is more natural than anything I've
ever done like it literally felt like
like it took a fish and threw him in the
water and he could swim like I just was
like that was just comfortable
completely comfortable um give me the
first thing you landed I'm sure you do
it was uh the first thing I land it was
a show called China Beach an ABC show
that was a big hit at the time it was
like you know 20 lines a couple of
little scenes but man it was just I was
just in heaven and it was the validation
cuz like you know growing up I always
wanted to be a professional basketball
player and I never even came close to
that and then when you're like I want to
be an actor and then you you go in an
audition you get the part and then
you're on a set I was like man it was
such a fulfilling thing that was yeah it
was like it was like you know like if I
still to this day I had one the other
day I told my wife she
I I said I had a dream that I was
playing for the Detroit Pistons I don't
know why I wasn't but I still have
dreams that I play professional
basketball and when I did that China
Beach and the first few things like it
was that elation like hey I can't
believe I'm doing this and I never got I
think that's why I still have dreams of
playing basketball because although I
don't even play basketball it's still a
big part of my it was such a part of my
DNA to dream about that for long that I
still to this day have actual hoop
dreams how long were you doing how long
you auditioning before you finally
landed that back about a year oh so
there was yeah a lot of a lot of
failures first yeah you know to be
honest it wasn't that many I got lucky
you know I got I got I got lucky you
know like if you'd like about a year
you're like oh I've been audition for
since I got nothing like I was lucky it
was it was the right part at the right
time which led me to you know the other
things and I was lucky I didn't I didn't
suffer as an actor um but I think a lot
of that was because of my mindset about
it like I was not scared I've always
been a good audition or which as you
know is half the [ __ ] like you could
be a great actor and like be not good at
auditioning you won't get jobs right the
[ __ ] up especially when you're when
you're first starting out and I was
always a good audition er I was
comfortable with it I I enjoyed the
competition of it and and and you know
and I did well in it and then I got jobs
because they're two different sports
it's literally like playing lacrosse and
tennis there are two different skill
sets auditioning and actually being an
actual television or film actor so I got
lucky and I've had a bunch of good
breaks speaking of trying to figure out
the context of tweets I was looking you
were tweeting it a Joe button a couple
of days ago and I couldn't tell friends
that's what I thought yes friends oh so
yeah he's tweets backer like you could
you know there were friends and and I
love him and I think he's funny and he
is he's another one that's made a major
career for himself talking [ __ ] and he's
a great [ __ ] talker so yeah we're we're
cool were friendly and you know we're in
a fantasy football league and I play him
this week and I plan on beating
[ __ ] ass I told him I said Eminem's
gonna be the last thing you need to be
worrying about when you do all this
through this week and when we start this
fantasy football game you know III like
him so but yeah but yeah that's that's
right you talk a lot about a new hip hop
and you're critical of it mm-hmm like um
when the Eminem album came out you were
you were upset that there wasn't more
rappers some people did but there
weren't more people responding right
today like response was like yeah like
if you're talking [ __ ] like the reason
why I'm in and made this record and the
reason why I'm Adam came in people which
like in his earlier thing he would just
come at people he didn't like but this
was like a response you've been talking
[ __ ] about me this one that one Joe
button you know die Antwoord and all
these people and now I'm putting on a
record
highly skilled tremendously skilled
record this kamikaze record like his his
level of rapping in the art form it's
like some like Ornette Coleman jazz [ __ ]
another love you did right so he's
talking his [ __ ] you think uh you you
guys are saying I suck I'm old I'm
washed up okay here we go here you go
I'm talking to you I'm talking into and
no one's saying anything and I'm like
this doesn't have to turn into some
violence you you had a comment about my
last record I'm saying you ain't [ __ ]
you you have no right to even speak on
me so what's up could it be that they're
waiting to respond is I could waiting
they're like you have nothing to say
it's like the one kid came back and that
was good for him like a show to show you
in Cali and that was that was a gallant
choice that he said things it was cool
but it's like everybody else like if I'm
talking to you in Japanese and I you
know I'm saying [ __ ] you Jim you know
you bald [ __ ] and I'm saying this
in Japanese right yeah and you don't
respond back to me in Japanese then
there's no argument right but but so he
came out as a rapper in in in rap music
and rap form
there's no tweeting there's no YouTube
videos there's no podcasting he's a
respond back as a rapper or shut up take
the loss acknowledge the loss and don't
spit out those so those same people
Tyler the Creator
die Antwoord D you know you had
all these things to say now he came at
you now don't comment on M&M again don't
say anything about him well Nicki Minaj
walked away from that fight without who
is it Remy Ma Remy Ma she just stopped
and it just kind of went away so I think
that that's what she put out a lot more
fire after right she started putting out
hits Remy Ma yeah and then and then Remy
Ma put out some other stuff what didn't
Drake stop responding to yes so like I
think once in a while if you kind of get
your dick kicked in you're like alright
we'll move along and it didn't hurt
Drake it also maybe I'm thinking too
I agree but but for me yeah who's a real
purist and and hip-hop means so much to
me as a fan it's like you need to you
need to like in in the in the the
competition of hip-hop it's built on
competition who's the best braggadocious
you know I got I got you know from
rapper's delight' you know to - I got
limousines and you know watching Nick
games and color TVs and also that's the
sport of hip-hop that's that's the genre
of hip-hop it's part of the music you
have to respond so when you're talking
about like how I was like hip-hop is
dead right and and and you know like
otherwise you know and at the end of the
day like don't say don't talk [ __ ] if
you're not willing to like you know get
it back and if you're willing to get you
know like you got to be able to like it
as a [ __ ] talk you have to be able to to
to take it as good as you give it right
right half and respond to it yeah you
have to be able to take it you can't be
sensitive you you you like if you're
gonna talk [ __ ] you have to be able to
receive it because other people can talk
[ __ ] to write more people are good at it
- exactly
so when you when you get critical that
was like a threat Jim when you say when
you get critical of like young hip hop
acts and young rappers and stuff like
that do you ever get to this moment
where you're like oh maybe this has just
passed me by you know what I mean maybe
I'm not a maybe in my my definition of a
purist is I just don't relate to young
people anymore you know I I understand
that and I and that is true you know I
think all great music is is spawned and
stemmed it from youth whether it's the
punk rock movement or or or the what we
call the the classic rock movement you
know like the Beatles Rolling Stone
Led Zeppelin they were 21 22 23 blues
you know like all those artists were
young Miles Davis John Coltrane Dizzy
Gillespie oh that whole gamut of people
young hip-hop young 17 18 19
you know rock can run DMC they're
teenagers so I get that it's I get that
it's it's sort of a it's a youthful
sport I think music at its best is
youthful right did the Rolling Stones we
why sit sit here I love hearing them
watching them perform but we don't want
to really hear no new [ __ ] we want to
hear right let it bleed you know we want
to hear that old [ __ ] we want to see
Mick a thank God he's still alive sing
[ __ ] under my thumb because that's
when you were on fire so I get that but
but to not respect like we we have Mick
Jagger right we don't have Jimi Hendrix
we don't have the Beatles we don't have
Led Zeppelin if we did we would be happy
as [ __ ] to see Jimi Hendrix rocking at
80 right now right so gotcha
we wouldn't be like Jimi Hendrix as old
as [ __ ] to be like look at this
[ __ ] getting down you know what
I mean but some reason hip hop like
you're 40 and all of a sudden you're a
piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah I've noticed
but that's starting to change a little
bit like with like you run DMC touring
again and there it seemed like they were
doing I noticed that too there wasn't
enough respect to a lot of the older
guys yeah but it seemed that that
changed a little bit like you know like
the rows of you like Mick is eight he
was like thank God he's [ __ ] still
doing yeah what would you to be able to
see you know Jimi Hendrix sitting on a
stool doing gym like how much how much
value with that or or I mean Johnny Cash
performs until he was dead James Brown
did it till he was dead
yeah you know Sammy Davis jr. did it so
he said like you know like sitting there
going to go look at Mick and Keith you
look at them they're right there killing
it right and the music still sound to do
in arenas Ball State imagine seeing the
Beatles doing they're like an acoustic
set or like what he's doing with what
Bruce Springsteen was doing on Broadway
like imagine that if they were alive and
able to do that they can sell out
forever
I'm so so so with hip hop like I just
thought like I get a fan I'm like don't
eat what made this don't like piss and
[ __ ] on what made action you know in
like with young rappers saying I
I never listen to what Aang did you
leave the studio you should be ashamed
up because if you never listen to one
thing first of all whether you're in
hip-hop or not your credibility is is
that is nothing but if you're in hip-hop
and you're sitting here proudly with a
smile on your face and I never listen to
Moo Tang we like get the [ __ ] out of
here talk to swing them I'm like shut
the mics on these people like you never
listen to one thing and you're proud of
that I would be that's something to be
embarrassed that's like saying like an
NBA first-round draft pick being like
who's Larry Bird that's like saying I've
never watched the show a typical on
Netflix right season too humiliating
humiliation you [ __ ] you can trust me
I'm gonna devour season two you know i
love season one
[Music]